phosphorus pentachloride will decompose
into phosphorus trichloride
and chlorine gas kp for this reaction is
equal to 0.500 at 500 kelvin
let's say that this reaction is at
equilibrium in a reaction vessel that
has a volume of 2.0 liters
and the equilibrium partial pressure of
pcl5
is equal to 0.980 atmospheres the
equilibrium partial pressure of pcl3 is
equal to 0.700 atmospheres
and the equilibrium partial pressure of
chlorine gas is equal to 0.700
atmospheres
if we add up those three partial
pressures we get the total pressure
of the gas mixture at equilibrium which
is equal to 2.38 atmospheres
and we're going to call this total
pressure p1
if we decrease the volume from 2 liters
down to 1 liter
and we t we keep the temperature
constant at 500 kelvin
we decrease the volume by a factor of 2
which means we increase
the pressure by a factor of two so all
of the partial
pressures of our gases double and
there's a new total pressure
which is twice the original total
pressure and this new total pressure is
equal to 4.76
atmospheres and from now on we'll call
this total pressure p2
so when the volume was 2 liters the
reaction started out at equilibrium
and by decreasing the volume to 1 liter
and by doubling the pressure we've
introduced a stress
to the system and so at this moment in
time when when these are the partial
pressures the reaction is
not at equilibrium
le chatelier's principle says the net
reaction will move in the direction that
decreases the stress
so if the stress is an increase in the
pressure the net reaction
will move in the direction that
decreases the pressure
looking at the balanced equation there's
one mole of gas on the reactant side
and there are two moles of gas on the
product side
so if the net reaction goes from the
products to the reactants if the nut
reaction goes to the left
the net reaction is going to the side
with the smaller
number of moles of gas which would
decrease the pressure
and relieve the stress the net reaction
keeps moving to the left
until equilibrium is re-established and
when equilibrium is re-established
there'll be a new total pressure which
we'll call
p3 so our goal is to calculate
p3 so we can compare it to
p1 and p2 and we're going to do this
in a quantitative way and in a more
qualitative way
let's use an ice table to help us figure
out the final total pressure p3
in an ice table i stands for the initial
partial pressure in this case
c is the change in e is the equilibrium
partial pressure
the initial partial pressure of pcl5
after the volume was reduced to 1 liter
was 1.96 atmospheres and the partial
pressures of pcl3 and cl2 were both 1.40
atmospheres
we already used le chatelier's principle
to realize the net reaction is going to
go
to the left which means we're going to
decrease
in the amount of our products and we're
going to increase the amount of the
reactants
so if we're going to increase the amount
of pcl5 we don't know how much we're
going to increase we're going to call
that
x but we know it's going to increase so
we write plus x under the change part on
the ice table
and since our mole ratio of pcl5 to pcl3
is one to one
if we're gaining x for pcl5 we must be
losing
x for pcl3 and the same goes for cl2
since there's a coefficient of one so we
write minus
x in our ice table therefore the
equilibrium partial pressure of pcl5
would be 1.1.96
plus x the equilibrium partial pressure
of pcl3 would be 1.40 minus
x and the equilibrium partial pressure
of cl2 would also be
1.40 minus x next we can plug in the
equilibrium partial pressures into
our kp expression so we can plug in 1.40
minus
x for the equilibrium partial pressure
of pcl3
1.40 minus x for the equilibrium partial
pressure of cl2
and 1.96 plus x for the equilibrium
partial pressure of pcl5
and we can also plug in the value for
the equilibrium constant kp
here's what our equilibrium constant
expression looks like with everything
plugged
in and next we would need to solve for x
which would involve the use of a
quadratic equation
and when you do all that math you find
that x is equal to
0.330
now that we know x is equal to 0.33 we
can solve for the equilibrium partial
pressures
1.96 plus 0.33 is equal to 2.29
therefore the equilibrium partial
pressure of pcl5 is 2.29 atmospheres
for pcl3 it's 1.40 minus x
1.40 minus 0.33 is equal to 1.07
therefore the equilibrium partial
pressure of pcl3 is equal to 1.07
atmospheres
it's the same math for cl2 so the
equilibrium partial pressure of
cl2 is also 1.07
atmospheres so to find the total
pressure p3 we simply need to add
up the individual partial pressures so
2.29 plus 1.07
plus 1.07 is equal to 4.43
atmospheres therefore p3
is equal to 4.43
atmospheres doing the math helps us
realize that x is not a very large
number
and the reason why x is not a very large
number is because the kp value
is equal to 0.500 for this reaction
and when k is close to 1 there's an
appreciable amount of both reactants and
products at equilibrium
and we can see that with our equilibrium
partial pressures there's an appreciable
amount of both of them
and since there has to be a decent
amount of both reactants and products at
equilibrium
we're not going to see a huge change
from these initial partial pressures
so there will definitely be a shift to
the left
to decrease the pressure and when these
were the partial pressures if remember
p2 was equal to 4.76
so there's gonna be a decrease of
pressure so there's going to be a
decrease so the pressure is going to go
down from
4.76 but since there's not a large
change it's not going to be it's not
going to be a huge change and that's why
we saw
p3 only drop to 4.43 atmospheres
so if we go back to the original problem
and our goal is to figure out
p3 in relation to p1 and to p2 without
doing all that math
we could think to ourselves okay so we
decreased the volume by a factor of two
which
doubled the total pressure but then the
net reaction moves to the left to
decrease the pressure
since it's not going to move much to the
left it's not going to decrease the
pressure by a lot
therefore the final pressure p3 is going
to be
a little less than 4.76 but greater than
2.38
atmospheres